[Music]
I'm sure by now all of you have seen the
New York Times article on the
intellectual dark web that ran last week
the article was a heavy-lift trying to
define something that had been
previously undefined but it was a solid
foray into the mainstream for this
eclectic group of people for the record
I believe the intellectual dark web is a
diverse group of thinkers interviewers
comedians and academics who've been
thrust together due to intellectual
curiosity a desire for truth and an
absolute respect for our audience's
ability to make up their minds for
themselves
there's an old Groucho Marx line I
wouldn't want to belong to a club that
would have me as a member at first that
was how I felt about this intellectual
dark web we've had a pretty great thing
going around this loosely associated
group of free thinkers
so why muck it up with something more
formal what I've come to see though is
that this Alliance whether we have
membership cards in a clubhouse or not
is now one of the most important forces
for reason that exists this crew of
people from Harris to the Weinstein
brothers and from Shapiro to Somers have
all come from different walks of life
and from different academic and career
backgrounds what I believe to be the one
unifier in this group is that we haven't
been going for easy answers to tough
questions which make great sound bites
but offer little real-world value we've
all tried with success and sometimes
with failure to communicate ideas that
the mainstream media has either ignored
or misrepresented because they often go
against mainstream orthodoxy for example
Sam Harris has tried to make a clear
distinction between ideas and people and
why we must be able to criticize ideas
such as Islam without becoming bigoted
towards Muslim people progressive Brett
Weinstein has tried to show a
progressive university that fighting
racism through racist acts in this case
a day of absence at school for white
people was actually itself racist ben
shapiro has brought basic ideas of
conservatism to a younger generation
that is being indoctrinated with
postmodern viewpoints Christina Hoff
Sommers has tried to show people that
the original intention of feminism a
true equality for women
morphed into something about
authoritarianism rather than equality
all of these conversations are important
ones to have because without
conversation on these important issues
the only option left is violence it
doesn't mean that you have to agree with
anyone or everyone in this group of
people and they themselves disagree on
many issues with each other but the
failure of the mainstream to honestly
and maturely talk about these topics is
exactly what drove so many of you guys
to us in the first place
contrary to many of the think pieces
written after the original New York
Times piece none of us none of us in
this dark web view ourselves as victims
actually it's the total reverse we're
empowered by our ideas in my case the
belief in the individual and want you to
be empowered to fight for what you
believe in as well even when you
disagree with us I do want to address a
few questions related to my role in all
this discussion as well as how I view
myself and the Rubin record as a show
one of the criticisms by Barry Weiss in
The Times article was in essence about
the gatekeeping responsibility that she
feels the members of the intellectual
dark web should have so where are the
lines we draw as to who we talk to and
what our ideas which we won't touch if a
conversation we're having could lead you
down a rabbit hole of unsavory people is
it incumbent on us to guard you against
this journey or is it on you as the
viewer to decide what ideas and which
people cause you to draw your own line I
think you know my position on this but
I'll say it again i as an individual
make the choices which I think are
intellectually honest and then I believe
that it is on you the viewer as an
individual to decide which people and
ideas you like or dislike and then
follow up on these people and ideas
yourself I've always felt this was the
right way to look at being an
interviewer but I know that not everyone
agrees with this premise including some
people I like and respect I also have
said many times before along the way of
making these decisions I may make
mistakes but I'll always try to do what
I think is right there's also an
interesting guilt by association
situation developing here my friend and
mentor Larry King the true king of
interviewing could spend a week in 1994
interviewing David Duke Louis Farrakhan
the cast of sign
Michael Jordan and Frank Sinatra nobody
in their right mind ever felt that that
meant he was friends with or endorsed
all of these people's views somehow and
maybe this is just partly because of
YouTube and social media these days if
we even talked to someone a certain
segment of people think that this
automatically means you stand by
everything they've said and done I view
this is patently absurd and actually
quite dangerous we have to be willing to
push the sensible boundaries of people
were willing to talk to otherwise we're
just talking to ourselves and thus
furthering the echo-chamber mentality
that mainstream media fosters this
brings me to a couple people who have
had conversations with I seem to get the
most guff from having two specific
people on the Rubin report as well as
one interview I did outside of the show
I had Mike Serna [ __ ] on the Rubin
report in March of 2016 right when the
Trump phenomena was first breaking
through at the time I saw a lot of
support online for Trump but I couldn't
find any mainstream people willing to
talk about it
Serna [ __ ] was one of the few vocal
supporters of Trump was a published
author and was catching fire on Twitter
my conversation with Mike was totally
civil and actually quite interesting to
me as I hadn't heard anyone articulate
sensible support for Trump before that
point as the next two years unfolded
Serna [ __ ] was a central figure in
conspiracy theories such as pizza gate
while also being at the front of
Hillary's health issues which the media
ignored until she passed out in front of
her SUV on that fall day in New York
City in 2016 let's not forget the Donna
Brazile the former head of the DNC
actually confirmed
Serna [ __ ] reporting when she said
that the DNC was thinking about
replacing Hillary at one point during
the campaign I didn't know about some of
Mike's distasteful blog post which were
written before I sat down with him and I
certainly can't be held accountable for
what anyone does after they've been on
the show what I can be held accountable
for is the way I conduct myself in an
interview with a controversial person
which thus far I'm absolutely proud of
one of the reasons I wasn't surprised by
the election of Donald Trump was because
that very conversation that I had with
cerned a [ __ ] led me to believe it was
going to be a possibility
so while mainstream media ignored
figures which were deemed deplorable and
felt that Hillary was a shoo-in
dared have the conversations which
allowed me and hopefully you to see the
future more clearly the other interview
which people were upset by was my chat
with stefan molyneux stefan is heavily
focused on race and IQ which is not a
discussion I'm a pro at nor one that I
care to focus on that much actually I
asked him this very question during the
interview what is it about race and IQ
that you feel the need to talk about it
so much his answer in essence was that
he talks about it because he finds it so
troubling his answer is for you the
viewer to either accept or reject
perhaps I could have poked or prodded in
another way but I felt trying to figure
out why he thinks as he does is what my
job is the other important one to
address here is an interview that I did
on the Alex Jones Show back in February
of last year this was right after my why
I left the left video came out from
Prager University and I was getting a
ton of press requests that week I also
did Tucker Carlson on Fox News and would
have been just as happy to do MSNBC or
CNN had they invited me my feelings as I
have said in a bunch of live stream
since was that if I went on jones's show
and it was aired live and unedited I
might be able to bring my message of
conversation and classical liberalism to
Jones's audience I know it worked by the
way because I've received dozens of
messages from Jones's fans who said how
nice it was to hear a different
perspective and since then they've been
challenged by other interviews that we
do right here the criticism of course is
that I somehow legitimize Jones by doing
his show in the first place I don't see
it that way myself but I'm sympathetic
to the argument and as Uncle Ben said to
Peter Parker with great power comes
great responsibility I didn't think that
a year ago I had great power but as
things have ramped up around here it
appears that I do these days
I should also remind you that there are
plenty of people who wouldn't want me to
sit down with Jordan Peterson because
they say he's alright or Sam Harris
because they say he's anti-muslim
charges that I and you know absolutely
to not be true this is the dangerous
place we're all in when we all act like
the gatekeepers of others capacity to
make this
for themselves with all this in mind I'd
like to offer up three Rubin report
rules going forward one I will keep the
focus more on ideas than on people this
won't always be totally possible but
I'll always do my best to honor that
principle too I'll continue to interview
potentially controversial people but
will increase my efforts to shed light
on ideas that they have that I'm
concerned or unsavory
I'll give them a chance to explain
themselves as I believe that sunlight of
course is the best disinfectant if I'm
cordial to someone it doesn't mean that
I endorsed them I think we're in serious
danger of eliminating conversations that
are necessary to understanding the big
picture because some of us may feel
compromised by simply listening
Trump's election and brags it were only
surprises if you turned up your nose to
listening to half the electorate three
I'll keep trying to build bridges in
some places where others would
reflexively burn them down this is
always tricky because I naturally don't
want to legitimize bad actors but I'll
always try to see if there's room to
make inroads with someone where I may
have been trained to think that they
were my sworn enemy my bridges won't be
built everywhere though we've got to
have some standards of decency to make
sure that the ideas we want to build
upon here aren't sitting on a mound of
quicksand as what we do here gets put
more into the spotlight I have more of a
responsibility to live up to the ideals
that I've laid out here I'm never gonna
make everyone happy and it's why at the
end of the day I can only answer to my
own conscience I believe that we are
starting to win in the public square and
this will now bring all sorts of new
people our way 2018 is undoubtedly the
year of unusual alliances the invites
have been sent out so now let's see who
shows up to the party
[Music]